foreign Max one more offense and you'll
be behind bars Flora you're his mother
find him something to do
what are you doing right now
you don't want to know
you are a great mother am I happy
birthday what's that it's yours don't
want to play since one of Mike is
harassed I can't go on like this living
in a shoe box with a kid who hates me
can't wait for the day I don't have to
be here
learned the guitar myself that's just
tell for me it takes years of practice
commitment are you really going to talk
to me about commitment
we're ready to teach you how to shred on
guitar
so you want to learn the guitar this is
a gift you can take to your grave what's
your problem I didn't know I had a
problem
we're teaching guitar online love what
are you hoping to get out of this I
thought this guitar might make me some
think I'm cool I'll be back in an hour I
don't care I don't know very annoying
what is that
your Club in here turn it down a second
was that yours
how did you make that it sounded epic
come on girl let's get in trouble
shaking not stir the James Bond from
Dublin
why don't you just grow can I try that
on it's too big that's the look
yeah for tortless
she's totally out of my league let's
write a song just to hear your passion
Express Yourself
she hated it yo just get out of my way
gladly
17 with the screaming child I mean like
this can't be my story
but without him I have nothing
how come the way things are never enough
for you
they never were
[Music]
playing the guitar and so sexy okay is
that why you took it off let's focus on
you
are you coming on to me
[Music]